look at this footage Indian Armed Forces
under orders from narender Modi are
about to do battle with the Chinese
people's Liberation Army the location
the disputed border region of the galwan
river valley and this isn't the first
time conflict has flared up here but
there's something strange about this
battle look closely neither side is
using modern Weaponry it's all just
hand-to-hand combat why is this well the
galwan river valley sits on a disputed
border between India and China both
nuclear armed Nations this Flash point
and the nation's reluctance to use guns
and explosives shows us how much is at
stake if the conflict ever went hot The
Fallout would be catastrophic with 25%
of the world's population living in
India and China the relationship between
the two nations may come to be a
defining theme of the 21st century I've
already gone down the rabbit hole of
seun ping but now I want to look at the
other half of the equation who is
narendro Modi really can he lead India
to rival China and how did he come to
govern more people than any other other
leader on
Earth Narendra Modi was born into humble
beginnings just after India gained
independence from British colonialism
born in Gujarat his father sold tea and
his home didn't even have Windows but
narendro wasn't your average child
around 8 years old he began taking a
keen interest in a local organization
called the rria swam seong his
experience in the RSS is fundamental to
understanding who Modi would become the
RSS was an organization founded on the
principles of an Indian nationalist
ideology called hindutva according to
hindutva in order to be truly Indian you
have to be Hindu by the time Modi joined
the RSS was already Infamous across
India the famous leader Mahatma Gandhi
was assassinated by an RSS member who
had taken issue with his attempts to
reconcile differences between Indian
Muslims and Hindus this didn't prevent
Modi from joining and the man who
enrolled him was named lakman inamar
remember inamdar because he will be a
key character in Mod's r rise to power
by 1967 Modi had grown into a young man
graduated high school and was ready to
climb the ranks of the RSS but there was
a problem Mod's parents had arranged for
him to be married to a local girl this
was a problem because the RSS prohibited
their members from marrying and doing so
would mean that he'd be expelled from
the organization risking being shunned
by his family and Community Modi
abandoned his bride to be and left
Gujarat after years of soul searching at
various holy sites Modi would eventually
return home visiting the RSS
headquarters and reconnecting with his
early Mentor inamdar inamdar saw
something in the young Modi he was full
of energy and idealism but most
importantly he was passionate about
Hindu culture with this in mind he
pushed Modi to take up politics joining
the Bara janas the rss's political party
so by this point a young and poor Modi
had grown into a politically determined
young man and found his calling through
an namdar in the RSS but we need to add
some context to what was going on in
India at the time during the collapse of
colonialism the British made a
catastrophic miscalculation South Asia
was made up of three main religious
groups Hindus Muslims and siks when the
British left they made the decision to
partition the region across these
religious lines however this created
pockets of minorities in each region
totaling nearly 15 million people
fearing sectarian violence most chose to
flee their homes and migrate across the
newly made borders the ensuing chaos led
to the deaths of over 2 million people
and the effects were ated throughout
history still causing tensions today
this event would be fundamental to how
India would eventually codify its
Constitution declaring India a sovereign
socialist secular Democratic Republic
this secularism was important because
today even after the partition about 1
billion Indians are Hindu 170 million
are Muslim and the remaining are either
sik or Christian early leaders like
Gandhi knew that for India to thrive
there would need to be peace between
these groups but this wasn't guaranteed
and the tensions would soon spill over
into violence at the time the Muslim and
Hindu regions of Bengal had been divided
up between Pakistan and India but in
1970 Rising Bengali nationalism resulted
in a pro Bengali party winning enough
seats to form a government and push for
Independence Pakistan refused to
acknowledge the election results and in
response launched a Crackdown named
Operation search light it was a brutal
campaign that many have labeled the
genocide the following day Bengali
leaders declared their independence the
Bangladesh Liberation War had begun so
by this point India was being led by
Indira Gandhi and she had found herself
facing a humanitarian crisis millions of
bengalis fled the fighting and sought
refuge in India struggling with the
influx of migrants indir Gandhi took
action and declared war on Pakistan in
December of
1971 this was the Nationalist cause
Narendra Modi had been looking for but
he would never get the chance to take up
arms for his people 2 weeks later
Pakistan Was Defeated and Bangladesh was
born but Modi was about to find another
cause to fight for India's leader indar
Gandhi was about to plunge the country
into an unprecedented
crisis the president has proclaimed
emergency this is nothing to panic about
the emergency is a pivotal moment in
Indian history and granted Indira Gandhi
unprecedented power at this point I
should clarify that Indira Gandhi wasn't
related to Mahatma Gandhi it's just a
common name in fact Indira was the
daughter of India's former leader jawah
haral nou who many call the architect of
Modern India during the Cold War Neu had
been an advocate of Indian neutrality
not wanting to be sucked into a war
between the great powers of the USSR and
the USA but when the USA announced they
would sell weapons to Pakistan India's
historic enemy India began leaning
toward the Soviet Union Neu visited
Moscow in 1955 resulting in Nikita
kushev agreeing to provide military aid
to India with the two countries becoming
more economically aligned it wasn't long
until Soviet Doctrine began cre creeping
into Indian politics nou lavish State
resources on heavy Industries like steel
coal mining and power generation in a
speech outlining India's second 5-year
plan nou said we must start with the
production of the machine which makes
the machine after his death his daughter
Indira picked up where her father left
off after becoming prime minister she
nationalized India's coal steel and
refining Industries she took control of
the country's 14 largest banks and in
1971 signed a treaty with the USSR
promoting Co operation on a wide range
of topics this was the largest
centralization of power in India's
history and led some to refer to Indira
Gandhi as the Empress of India but
discontent was never far from the
surface the reforms led to rapidly
Rising food prices and caused huge
strikes in Narendra Mod's home state of
Gujarat similar protests broke out in
the eastern Indian state of biar a
massive Railway strike brought the
country to a standstill and yet those
issues paled in significance to what
would come next on June 12th 197 5
Gandhi was found guilty of electoral
malpractice the court ordered that she
be stripped of her parliamentary seat
and under India's system of government
you had to be a member of parliament in
order to be a prime minister the times
of India compared the verdict to firing
the Prime Minister for a traffic ticket
but inir Gandhi didn't budge she
declared a national state of emergency
citing imminent threats to the Indian
State the emergency was one of the most
controversial periods of India's modern
history many of Gandhi's political
opponents were thrown in jail the
government even exploited the suspension
of democracy by embarking on a force
sterilization program to control Rising
population levels in addition to being
highly controversial the emergency was
also the making of Narendra Modi despite
being part of the now-banned RSS Modi
had been a prominent activist during the
emergency gaining reputation for action
and receiving publicity in National
Publications despite the RSS being
pushed underground Modi was still
politically active joining Gandhi's
opposition the jonata party finally
after 20 months indir Gandhi ended the
emergency and called Fresh elections her
tight grip of the media and large
industry made Indira confident she would
win but she was wrong for the first time
ever Congress lost power in India and
they didn't just lose they were crushed
by the opposition jata party a marriage
of convenience between several
opposition parties including one that
Modi had joined years earlier maraji
Desai became the first non- Congress
prime minister of India this was a huge
Turning Point Congress had dominated
Indian politics since before
Independence mamag Gandhi and Neu gave
it an aura that made it seem unbeatable
but the party's arrogance and
complacency opened the door Modi sensed
an opportunity after the ban on the RSS
was overturned he went to India's
capital Delhi there he wrote the rss's
official history of the emergency years
he was literally writing history and at
the same time he was building a
reputation for himself soon fate would
provide him with an even bigger
opportunity the janata party which won
the 197 27 elections soon face the
problem that confronts every protest
party created in a crisis what happens
when you solve the problem you were
created to solve the janata party was an
unwieldly Alliance it brought together
Hindu nationalists Farmers rights
Advocates socialists and even a renegade
faction of the congress party those
contradictions as well as the pressures
of leadership led to its collapse one of
the main problems was that the national
leadership of the Hindu nationalists
were much more moderate than the
Grassroots the National leadership
wanted to run the country and win
another election while the Grassroots
were strongly connected to the RSS some
members were even accused of involvement
in sectarian riots that took place in
1978 and
1979 that frustrated modernizers within
the national party as well as their
Coalition Partners eventually a fragment
of the party broke off to form a secular
Revival this meant the government lost
its parliamentary majority voters
weren't impressed they punished the
jonat party in the 1980 general election
reducing it to just 31 out of 531 seats
part of the problem was the state of the
economy thanks in part to the economic
planning of the National Congress by
1981 India was ryant on loans from the
international monetary fund following
the elections the executive Council of
the jonata party concerned that voters
perceived it as too extreme decreed that
its members couldn't also be members of
the RSS that only worse than the split
between the leadership and the
Grassroots so in April of 1980 the
members created a new political party
with close ties to the RSS they called
it the Indian people's party but it goes
by BJP and narender Modi was one of its
first members although by then indir
Gandhi was again prime minister hopes
were high for the BJP but no one was
counting on what happened next good
evening indir Gandhi ruler of the
world's largest democracy died today
shot down by two of her own bodyguards
they were siks taking revenge for the
invasion of their temple in June and
tonight mobs of Hindus have been
attacking siks in cities throughout the
subcontinent the assassination of Indira
Gandhi stemmed from Operation Blue Star
an Indian military plan to remove a
charismatic sik militant from one of the
holiest sites in seism official numbers
put the death toll at more than 550 seik
militants and civilans and 83 soldiers
distraught and enraged Gandhi's
bodyguard shot her as an act of Revenge
36 years later in the same city
sectarian violence had claimed the life
of another Indian leader named Gandhi
the retaliation was Swift and brutal in
the aftermath of the assassination an
estimated 8,000 siks were killed in
riots and targeted attacks mahat mandhi
and his Protege Neu knew that sectarian
violence was one of the biggest
challenges India would face following
Independence Mutual hatred of the
British helped keep a lid on violence
during the colonial era but Independence
and the chaos of partition threatened to
unleash a tital wave Gandhi's
assassination meant a new election was
required the BJP was led by atal Bahari
vajpai despite being one of the party's
co-founders his own moderate social
politics resembled Mahatma Gandhi's
socialism but in an election where
voters were sympathetic to the congress
party he simply didn't give people a
strong enough reason to vote for him the
BJP won two seats in India's Parliament
the failure of his moderate strategy
caused the party to search for a
different way forward an opportunity
presented itself right away the vhp a
member of the group of nationalist
organizations led by the RSS began a
campaign to construct a Hindu Temple
dedicated to the of Rama in a popular
city they believed that the site was
Rama's birthplace there was only one
problem there was already a mosque on
the site the BHP went all in on the
campaign to demolish the Bob mosque that
made the congress party very nervous
Rajiv Gandhi who took over his prime
minister after his mother indira's
assassination wanted to neutralize the
issue by promising to permit Hindu
prayer at the babri MOs after that
angered Muslims he appeased them by
Banning the import of Solon Rush's book
The Satanic Verses then when that didn't
work he endorsed the construction of a
Hindu temple in the city while all this
was going on the RSS sent its Rising
Star Narendra Modi to Gujarat his job
was to whip the party into shape and
organize its campaigns in Municipal
elections in the city of madad the
campaign was a huge success and today
official biographies credit Modi as The
Mastermind behind the scenes as a reward
in 1987 he was promoted to organizing
Secretary of the bjp's garat branch his
job was to increase the dominance and
popularity of the BJP and by extension
the RSS it wouldn't take very long for
both of those things to happen but it
didn't have all that much to do with
Modi the vhp's ability to mobilize
public opinion was tested in the city of
ioda in
1992 when a mob of their supporters
stormed the bub
mosque the aim was to destroy this
symbol of Islam the battle that followed
claimed 12200 lives and sparked a frenzy
of violence across India in late 19 1990
the bjp's leader made a pilgrimage to
the city when Hindu protesters showed up
in December police opened fire killing
dozens and further inflaming tensions
when protesters returned in 1992 they
overwhelmed security and attacked the
mosque with pickaxes hours later it was
nothing but dust and Rubble to this day
it's not clear if the destruction of the
Boby mosque was a spontaneous act or the
culmination of a carefully orchestrated
plan but what is clear is that several
leading Hindu nationalist figures
provoked it you might have thought that
because of India's high levels of
religious and ethnic diversity and the
pride its leaders took in cultivating
religious toleration that the
destruction of the Bradbery mosque would
have been bad news for the BJP it was
quite the opposite in 1995 the party won
a massive majority in the Gujarat state
election in the space of just 10 years
the Gujarat State Parliament went from
being dominated by the sky blue of the
congress party to being bathed in the
saffron orange of the BJP the best way
to describe what the BJP was doing was
that it was teaching Hindus to resent
the existing political system which had
been specifically crafted by the
congress party to avoid one group
dominating any other Hindus represented
the majority moreover they represented
India itself so why shouldn't they
receive special treatment given the
country's long history with religiously
motivated violence this was dangerous
thinking but it was intoxicating the
riots that culminated in the destruction
of the baby mosque were a symbol of a
country whose politics were changing
rapidly and Narendra was on the ground
driving that change the following year
the BJP became the largest party in the
National Parliament but before he could
turn his attention to New Deli Modi was
still needed at home the BJP were
running garat but they hadn't actually
chosen a leader one of them shank kersen
Vela was an experienced legislator the
other kashuba Patel had joined the RSS
before India gained independence the
bjp's leadership including Modi threw
their support behind Patel the gala
didn't exactly like that in fact he
rebelled and threatened to leave the
party terrified of losing the political
Advantage they'd worked so hard to
create the BJP backtracked and installed
veala as chief minister of Gujarat Modi
punished for backing the wrong horse was
temporarily banished from his home state
that still wasn't enough for Vila though
he still left the BJP in order to form
his own Splinter Group Bringing Down the
government in the process eventually
after fresh elections in February of
1998 the BJP emerged with a clear
majority Balo was out of the picture
Patel was installed as chief minister of
Gujarat meanwhile that same month
national elections produced an
inconclusive result Congress and the BJP
couldn't be separated after some
wrangling the BJP formed a coalition and
vayi was named prime minister and just
like that Gujarat and India were both
led by the BJP in May of 1998 Modi was
promoted to General Secretary but it
wouldn't be long until he was called to
hire post by 2001 Patel's Health was
failing and frankly so was his
government the bjp's national leadership
decided Gujarat needed a new Chief
Minister Modi didn't have any political
experience but he was an effective
organizer and deeply committed to the
goals of the BJP on October 3rd he was
appointed chief minister and given the
task of leading the BJP to victory in
the following year's election barely 2
weeks after his 50th birthday Narendra
Modi suddenly found himself leading a
state of more than 50 million people
after years of effort he had
accomplished something amazing but his
career as a politician was almost over
as suddenly as it
began
murder rape houses torched people burnt
alive over 1,000 people have died and
more than 100,000 have become refugees
in their own land the violence which
spread all across guerad began in late
February after this train carrying Hindu
pilgrims was attacked by
Muslims one Carriage was torched and 58
people died mostly women and children
Hindu mobs responded with murder and
Arsen India has never been a stranger to
violence for centuries zealots killed in
the name of their religion but this time
felt different because this time it felt
like the government was on the side of
the perpetrators the police and
authorities in garat were accused of
standing back and allowing the violence
to unfold or even encouraging it Human
Rights Watch said that the Gujarat State
administration had been engaged in a
massive coverup of the state's role in
the massacres 4 days after after the
violence broke out Narendra Modi and
India's home minister LK advani visited
the scene to call for peace but they
were both members of the BJP a party
which based its entire identity on Hindu
supremacism advani was even one of the
bjp's co-founders so a lot of people
questioned their sincerity especially
when it emerged that Modi had gathered
police at his home and ordered them not
to stop the Hindu backlash a secret
police document even seemed to show that
local police had conducted a secret
census to gain detailed information
about the Muslim Community and prepare
an attack during the riots Hindu houses
were left untouched while Muslim houses
right next door were destroyed the
extent to which Modi was personally
involved in the riots remains hotly
debated but legally the matter is closed
after 20 years of back and forth in the
legal system India's Supreme Court ruled
that he had no case to answer of course
by then Modi was prime minister and the
most powerful man in the country the BJP
held a convention a few weeks after the
riots party moderates sensing an
opportunity to get rid of an influential
rival pled on calling on him to resign
but when Modi spoke the crowd roared
their approval far from being the end of
his political career the riots in guara
were more like the beginning when it
came time for the next state elections
the BJP knew they had no other option
Modi was the only choice the election
was a referendum on the riots Modi went
on the attack framing criticism of his
government as an attack on Gujarati
pride and boasting that he had delivered
peace and stability to Gujarat his
strategy was successful the BJP won a
big majority and Modi had his first
election Victory the 2002 Gujarat
election campaign was a big turning
point in both modi's political career
and the trajectory of Indian Politics as
a whole because it proved once and for
all that doubling down on huva was
popular there was still some Fallout to
navigate from the riots when the BJP
surprisingly lost the 2004 general
elections the defeated BJP prime
minister AEL vayi cited the riots as a
reason for his defeat and even said it
was a mistake to let Modi stay in office
and Western nations were asking hard
questions about modi's role in the
Gujarat riots the George W Bush
Administration even denied him a visa to
the United States in 2005 but by now
Modi knew that despite what westerners
and Congress party supporters thought
he'd found a winning strategy he started
attending only Hindu religious
ceremonies on a couple of occasions he
even refused to wear clothing gifted by
Muslim leaders but he knew that people
needed more than just stunts they needed
him to govern so his second term as
chief minister of garat Modi rebranded
himself as an economic reformer again he
saw an opportunity to draw a contrast
with the congress party like I said
earlier congress's first generation of
leaders pursued socialist economics they
did things like invest in heavy industry
put up barriers to trade and subsidize
farmers in essence they chose
redistribution over economic growth you
know making sure everyone has an equally
large slice of the pie rather than
growing the pie bigger partly that was
because of their own beliefs about
economics but it was also about politics
handing out money to politically
important sectors of the economy won
lots of votes but that approach had
major long-term consequences for India's
economy at the start of the 1990s India
was still a closed system with a fixed
exchange rate and when that system led
to Major balance of payments problems
India's economy suddenly found itself in
crisis its share of global economic
output fell to 1% an all-time low that
crisis and the ensuing collapse of the
government ushered in some much needed
economic reforms barriers to Imports
were reduced subsidies for key
Commodities like fertilizer and sugar
were reduced and plans were made to sell
off public Enterprises India's leaders
didn't have to look very far to see how
more open economies could perform in the
1990s the Asian tigers achieved rapid
growth by opening their economies to
trade and foreign investment in 1950
India and South Korea had about the same
GDP but by the year 2000 South Korea was
about seven times richer per capita
that's not to say India didn't have
advantages like services but they didn't
scale as well as what was happening in
East Asia but changes in policies can
create changes in cultures no one
understood that better than narender
Modi he saw that a new middle class one
that was Pro business and pro
entrepreneurship was emerging sure lots
of them cared about their religion but
they also cared about getting good jobs
or starting businesses B's Secret Sauce
was pretty simple he made big
investments in basic infrastructure
reduced corruption and improved the
quality of governance and gave
businesses big handouts to attract
investment some people called his
approach modomics others called it the
Gujarat model during his time as chief
minister of Gujarat the state's economy
grew by 10% a year that was faster than
the country as a whole and it was enough
to inspire articles that compared
Gujarat to Guangdong the Chinese
province which underpinned China's
incredible growth during the 90s Hindu
nationalism and pro bus economics was a
powerful combination but Modi had
written the bjp's official history of
the emergency he knew that the person
who controlled the message had a huge
advantage in the runup to the 2012 garat
State elections Modi used holographic
technology and satellite link UPS to
address audiences across the state all
from a studio let's be honest the tech
isn't very impressive but that's not the
point the point is that he was in four
places at once Modi was making the most
of his huge personal appeal with the
sort of political skills that frankly
his political opponents just didn't seem
capable of and it wasn't just Holograms
either Modi also harnessed social media
better than anyone else in Indian
politics he crossed 1 million Twitter
followers weeks before the election
today he has 91 million he was also
active on Facebook maintained a Blog and
started to YouTube channel which hosted
a bunch of his speeches and press
conferences every road that was built
every village that was electrified every
new plant that was opened Modi talked
about them all and it made a big
difference Modi the politician was also
Modi the marketer it wasn't all smooth
sailing performance across indicators
like education and nutrition flatlined
or went backwards but whatever wasn't
part of the narrative didn't make it to
Twitter The Narrative was that gooda was
a dynamic fast-moving State led by a
dynamic fast-moving leader and after 12
years that leader was ready to mount his
challenge for the top
job during his 12 and 1/2 years as chief
minister of Gujarat Narendra Modi broke
the mold of Indian politics by combining
Pro bus economics and pro-hindu politics
he turned appeals to self-interest into
an ideology and in the process became
the most influential person in the BJP
and one of the most important people in
India but there was still one question
he had to answer could he scale that
political strategy from garat a state of
62 million people to a country of 1.3
billion in September of 2013 Modi was
named the bjp's candidate for prime
minister ahead of the 2014 elections and
almost immediately the campaign became a
referendum on him he promised to bring
the dynamic economic growth he'd helped
create mudrat to India broadly he
pledged to build a Hindu temple on the
site of the destroyed bobbery mosque he
pitched himself as the representative of
an authentic India a man battling to
take back the country from complacent
former leaders who didn't pay enough
attention to the concerns of the Hindu
majority just to prove his point a
senior Congress politician referring to
Modi said that a te- seller should never
become Prime Minister of India well he
did the BJP became the first party to
win a majority of seats in its own right
since 1984 they performed especially
well in parts of India that had recently
experienced violence among Hindus and
Muslims and despite that they still won
10% of the Muslim vote on May 26th 2014
Narendra Modi was sworn in as the 14th
prime minister of India it was the
culmination of a major shift decades in
the making the S parivar A family of
Hindu organizations like the RSS and the
BJP taught Hindus to vote in their own
self-interest and now that it was out
the genie wasn't going back in the
bottle Modi moved fast he immediately
strengthened links between the BJP and
the RSS the paramilitary organization
that upheld Hindu culture across India
he appointed RSS members to lead
universities and research institutions
and passed a bill to increase government
control over the appointment of Judges
while investigations were launched
against several NGS including Doctors
Without Borders on the grounds that they
were undermining economic growth
hindutva had become official government
policy so had neoliberal economics Modi
reduced government spending on Social
Services while cutting taxes as part of
the make in India initiative launched in
September of 2014 Modi opened key
sectors like Railways defense and
medical devices to higher levels of
foreign direct investment the next day
Modi visited the United States the
country that rejected his visa
application less than 10 years earlier
because of his role in the Gujarat riots
this time around Modi visited the us to
meet Barack Obama and address the UN he
was out of the western diplomatic Deep
Freeze in fact modi's first political
headache didn't come until November 2016
2 and a half years into his first term
and it was self-inflicted to break the
grief of corruption and black
money we have
decided that the 500
rupee and 1,000 rupe currency
notes presently in use will no longer be
legal tender from midnight tonight with
one press conference Modi made 86% of
India's currency disappear it was
classic Modi he identified a real
problem the use of black money that
funded corruption and terrorism and then
he devised a solution that caused almost
as many problems it was total chaos the
move led to prolonged cash shortages
people died waiting in line to deposit
their Bank notes it's estimated that the
move cost 1.5 million jobs and cut 1%
off India's GDP but it still didn't stop
India from being the fastest growing
economy in the world in 2016 Modi was
making a bet that despite the disruption
people would be impressed by his
decisiveness clearly people didn't mind
too much the BJP and its allies formed
government in six of the seven states
that went to the polls in 2017 including
India's most populous state of utar
Pradesh demonization wasn't modi's only
major economic reform during his first
term he also introduced a goods and
services Tas to simplify the country's
tax code that too had lots of
implementation problems when the first
GST returns were filed in August of 2017
the system crashed in the end
demonetization and the GST were both
part of a strategy that Modi had been
cultivating ever since he started making
a real name for himself during the
emergency he was a man of action it
wouldn't be long before he again needed
to show it at around 3:15 p.m. on
February 14th 2019 terrorists from the J
Muhammad carried out a major attack in
the AMA district a car Laden with more
than 100 kg of explosives rammed into
the crpf bus killing 40 Personnel in an
instant but the Fallout didn't end there
National Security was an important part
of modi's political brand so he couldn't
let this go by without a response
despite a Pakistan based terrorist group
quickly claiming responsibility Modi and
the rest of his government were quick to
blame Pakistan itself 12 days after the
attack the Indian military carried out a
crossb air strike although they claimed
it was a preemptive strike against a
terrorist training group open- Source
satellite imagery showed that no targets
of consequence were hit but tensions
between India and Pakistan still surged
to dangerous levels soldiers from both
sides exchanged small arms and mortar
fire Pakistan struck back with its own
retaliatory air strike inside jamu and
Kashmir the Prime Minister Imran Khan
even claimed that his military pilot
successfully locked on to Indian
military installations but chose to draw
bombs on open ground instead Pakistan
even shot down an Indian Air Force mig21
taking its pilot prisoner after a
nervous month the two sides eventually
agreed to end hostilities in March of
2019 but Modi always the political
entrepreneur saw an opportunity the
attack and subsequent skirmishes
happened just weeks before the next
general election and they became a core
part of his appeal for reelection the
campaign was about lots of things
National Security Democratic backsliding
and the performance of the economy but
just like in 2014 it was really about
just one man Narendra Modi in a campaign
dominated by nationalist rhetoric he
portrayed himself as the protector of
India and the protector of Hindus he was
rewarded with the highest vote share of
any party since 1989 the BJP had a
majority and Modi became India's most
powerful leader since Indira Gandhi the
2019 election marked a turning point in
how Modi governed India he shifted to a
more majoritarian agenda and intensified
attacks on press freedom and civil
liberties he immediately used his
mandate to do three things which Hindu
nationalists had been demanding first he
banned the practice of Triple talic A
practice whereby a Muslim man could
legally divorce his wife by saying the
Arabic word for divorce three times in a
row then he repealed the special
autonomous status of the Muslim majority
state of jamu and Kashmir previously
jamu and Kashmir was administered by
India without forly being part of India
the political reforms changed that they
turned jamu and Kashmir into two
separate union territories basically
Indian states which were controlled by
the federal government in New Delhi
after the legislation passed the region
was placed under lockdown for months
thousands of people who protested it
including hundreds of political leaders
were detained but it was Mod's third
action which attracted the most
criticism in December of 2019 India's
parliament passed an amendment to the
citizenship act to provide an
accelerated path to citizenship for
persecuted religious minorities from
Afghanistan Bangladesh and Pakistan
except there was one religious group
that was conspicuously excluded Muslims
the ACT allowed religion to be used as a
Criterion of citizenship under Indian
law for the first time was it a generous
humanitarian act or blatant anti-us
Muslim persecution or maybe even both
you decide the Supreme Court didn't hear
any challenges to either the
assimilation of jamu and Kashmir or the
citizen Amendment act it basically
proved that the critics who had warned
about Modi undermining Democratic
institutions were right but they
couldn't do anything to stop it Indians
weren't living in Gandhi or neu's India
anymore they were living in narender
Mod's India the passage of the
citizenship Amendment act led to more
religious violence riots between Hindus
and Muslims in New Delhi in March of
2020 left dozens of people dead and
hundreds injured people weren't just
targeted for their religion journalists
were shot at confronted about their
religion and prevented from documenting
violence targeting journalists was
nothing new in India or in many places
around the world but as Hindu
nationalists learned how to behave with
impunity attacks were becoming more
frequent and more Brazen Modi had
fulfilled the promises he made to his
supporters and the RSS there was just
one last thing he had to do India's
prime minister has laid the foundation
stone for a Hindu temple that's being
built on a site that's been contested
between Muslims and Hindus for decades
the temple is being constructed here in
the northern city of aoia almost 30
years after the Bob mosque was destroyed
by Hindu nationalists the Hindu
nationalist who ran the country showed
up to lay the foundation stone for the
Hindu temple that will one day replace
it Narendra Modi was sending a clear
signal to both his supporters and his
critics despite what the Constitution
might say India was a Hindu majoritarian
country the greatest challenge facing
narender Mod's critics is that he was
undermining democracy by Democratic
means he had changed India forever and
not just its laws and its culture either
since Modi became prime minister
investment in transport infrastructure
has tripled as a share of GDP the number
of airports is almost doubled India has
823 million Broadband connections and
750 million smartphones people use
technology to do their banking pay their
bills and follow the Prime Minister on
Twitter it's no wonder the majority of
the country's Hindus all one billion of
them love what he's doing narender Modi
has changed India but how has he changed
India's place in the
world when he first ran for Prime
Minister Modi didn't talk much about
foreign policy if he did it was mostly
through the lens of National Security
otherwise there just weren't many votes
in it but he's managed to craft an
effective foreign policy buil partly on
principles inherited from his
predecessors and partly on new
approaches for a changing World we've
spoken about a lot of the basic
components of India's foreign policy
already IND was hesitant about formal
alliances and didn't want to get
entangled in outside Wars Pakistan and
China have always been Rivals the Soviet
Union was a friend but not quite an ally
these remain principles of India's
foreign policy under Modi to this day
but lots has changed India has changed
and so has China China's emergence as an
assertive economic and military power in
the indo-pacific under Sean ping has
greatly unsettled India's leaders both
sides have grievances cun ping has
deepened already strong military ties
with Pakistan modi's decision to create
two new union territories in Kashmir
sparked Chinese concerns about India's
intentions in the area at the same time
India is nervous about the way Beijing
through the belon road initiative is
vying for influence with smaller South
Asian Nations that have traditionally
been in India's sphere of influence
fundamentally China's rise is an
existential threat to India's strategic
autonomy add in large doses of
nationalism from both sides and tensions
are inevitable that border Skirmish I
mentioned in the intro wasn't the first
one since Sean ping came to power and it
probably won't be the last but China's
rise hasn't just made India nervous it's
made the entire Western World nervous
and that's given narender Modi a major
opportunity a show of unity from the US
and three allies whose spheres of
influence span the Indo Pacific a region
under pressure on many fronts from an
increasingly assertive China the quad is
an informal grouping between India the
US Australia and Japan it says its goal
is a free and open indopacific but
everyone knows that it's really about
keeping China in check in addition to
talking about security challenges the
four nations also take part in regular
joint military exercises it's not quite
an alliance though just because India
under Modi wants to constrain Chinese
influence in Asia doesn't mean it agrees
that the West should be the dominant
power but the quad is a good example of
The Balancing Act Modi has been trying
to pull off with his foreign policy
Western leaders understand that India's
actions are essentially pragmatic no one
expects that India would join a
hypothetical conflict over Taiwan Russia
is still India's biggest arms supplier
and India has been buying heavily
discounted Russian oil ever since
Vladimir Putin invaded Ukraine an
invasion which Modi didn't condemn but
as the competition between China and the
West Begins to resemble a second Cold
War Narendra Modi is considering whether
this time India might need to pick a
side in June 2023 narendro Modi visited
the United States it was his seventh
visit overall but his first official
state visit he addressed a joint session
of US Congress for a second time a rare
honor afforded to leaders like Winston
Churchill and Nelson Mandela in the past
few
years there have
been many
advances in
AI artificial
intelligence at the same
time there have
been even more momentous development in
another
AI America and
India if Joe Biden was worried about how
Narendra Modi has undermined India's
historic commitment to democracy and
religious pluralism he didn't show it
conditionally slowly and maybe just
temporarily India under Narendra Modi is
Shifting closer to the West on important
matters of geopolitics there's still
distrust and reluctance from both sides
relationships defined more by Common
enemies than common interests can be
fragile but there is real progress since
Narendra Modi became prime minister
India and the US have stepped up
cooperation on defense trade and
emerging Technologies but the lasting
ties will probably be the economic ones
two months before modi's visit to the US
Apple opened its first store the company
now assembles 7% of its phones in India
just Days Later Foxon broke ground on a
$500 million Factory India now accounts
for 40% of the world's digital
transactions GDP is growing rapidly and
investment as a share of GDP is the
highest it's been for a decade at
current growth rates its economy will
overtake Germany's and Japan within 5
years and as Western countries and
companies look to diversify their supply
chains away from China India will look
like an increasingly attractive
proposition during the Cold War India
remained neutral between the United
States and the Soviet Union but the
reality is that India just didn't matter
very much back then today India is the
world's biggest country and an
increasingly important strategic player
it's one of the West's most important
Hedges against Chinese influence while
at the same time it's helping to prop up
Vladimir Putin in the Russian economy at
the heart of all of this is Narendra
Modi the te- seller son from Gujarat
he's made India more assertive in
international Affairs more Dynamic
economically and maybe most of all more
Hindu in its culture and politics today
he dominates India just as much as the
National Congress ever did he is by far
the world's most popular elected leader
in charge of the world's biggest
political party as the story of the 21st
century continues to be written he will
be one of its most important figures if
you want to learn about the life iner
care of another important world leader
just watch this video next thanks a lot